[Music]
this is our life every
possibility Stephanie Shu showing off
her singing chops at the 2023 Academy
Awards
[Music]
not only what we've known the everything
everywhere all at once actress helps
recreate the film on the Oscar stage
performing its nominated song this is a
life
stay
[Music]
speed we're performing uh this is a life
which is the song that's best original
song that's nominated uh David Byrne Sun
Lux and I think it's going to be really
special we're really excited to share it
and special it was especially for
Stephanie who didn't sing the original
song but got some love from her co-star
Jamie Lee Curtis
Stephanie shoe just sang and she can
sing I can't JB and Stephanie went head
to head for best actress in a supporting
role Jamie ultimately taking home the
trophy but not without thanking Steph
and the rest of the cast
wait just won an Oscar together I'm
taking this really seriously and this is
the thrill of my life
[Applause]
foreign